our monsoon season has brought plenty of
rain to our valley and while we need the
water desperately it has also caused
some major damage residents in one
sunrise manor neighborhood are telling
us it's been a constant issue with
floods debris and other problems
i don't know if we're going to do
sandbags or
what we're going to do but we're going
to do something to divert the water kim
kelsey has been a sunrise manor resident
for 26 years she enjoys the open land
but she says that comes with a price
when storms roll by
i don't like when it rips out our trees
and takes our power out three years ago
it took it out for five days the most
recent storms caused flooding inside her
property you can see her wood floors
covered by mud and damaged by the water
it was probably
maybe a foot and a half deep there you
know on the house and then my downstairs
got flooded my yard my sidewalk
everything got flooded if you look out
front there you can see where the water
came
the rock hard soil combined with the
heat allows rain when it happens to
quickly turn into raging rivers
according to the regional flood control
district we spotted several streets near
hollywood boulevard and charleston with
dried mud and debris from recent storms
these rocks are normally red we've
cleaned most of them off because it was
a big mess to come home to but you can
see they're all brown now i still have
to wash more
as the cleanup process continues our 8
news now weather team is forecasting
more storms to roll into the valley a
concern for kelsey both safety and
financially it's going to be thousands
of dollars i'm going to have to redo
floor and walls and
everything i still don't even know
exactly how it got in i think it just
got so high on the house
that it just seeped right through the
stucco
well we reached out to the regional
flood control district about this issue
and they tell us there is a project that
is under designed right now to provide
some relief no other details were
provided but they recommend flood
insurance and contacting the county for
ways to protect your property